I can easily watch an entire series in a
single day two days ten hours of
television a day and I didn't even like
[Music]
bingeing started by accident Netflix has
realized that loads of people were
gravitating towards washing shows and
bulk you know B that shows that you've
seen before friends Seinfeld Law & Order
er that's the surprise about it it's led
by the consumer the way that Netflix
tries to nudge you to watch more it's
very subtle little tricks they work out
very quickly when a show launches which
fund I was working why also in there
getting to the very end of an episode
and immediately the credits they
minimize it went to the spur corner off
the screen straightaway and
automatically load for next episode
that's how you sometimes get sucked into
watching a show for all three hours
without even noticing I have found that
people are deeply embarrassed by how
much they watch TV deeply embarrassed to
not be productive and take time off and
say actually I watched six hours of
television today because I needed to not
look at five different tabs on a work
computer I just needed to we also binge
to be part of the public conversation
[Music]
yeah lovely bag so I think there is an
anxiety about being caught up about this
content which is forcing people to binge
more also when we can identify with a
character it leads to the release of the
love hormone oxytocin it creates a bond
we have had such a wonderful morning a
series like big little lies which allows
you to look at the same event through
the eyes of very different characters
you're bound to be able to find a
character that you can relate to and go
on the journey with if you ever touch my
little girl like that again you're gonna
end it okay if we're making time to
watch a series end to end we are
potentially creating hours of space to
work with our emotions our relationships
[Music]
I have probably watched television with
over 700 people and so I've experienced
a lot of people having big emotions no
it's fun anymore
whatever happened to fun the episode
splats of Sex in the City which is the
one where Kirsten Johnson falls out of a
window causes people a lot of emotions
because it's an episode about moving on
from something
[Music]
I want to go to Paris
[Music]
our brains don't discriminate between
real activation and activation due to
imagined events binge watching means
that you're activating yourself to a
high degree for much longer periods of
time that's going to take longer for you
to come down from that episode for Game
of Thrones where missandei is headed a
much beloved character it's a very
graphic death will have triggered the
sympathetic nervous system wouldn't be
conducive to a good night's sleep
what makes Netflix stand out so well
there's a fact that they're able to
really experiment with the number of
characters that are in the number of
story arcs Netflix knows that you're
never gonna wash your show midway
through you're never gonna start in the
middle you're always gonna start from
the very beginning
so that's we've got Oasis for new black
which has a cast of about 40 so you know
you're able to have that level of depth
over an eight hour series then what you
would normally do if it was separated
into eight 60-minute chunk and shoved on
on a linear broadcast channel binging is
is a word that is has very negative
connotations to it right binging is to
shovel yourself we don't say I finished
a book but the reality is that some of
the greatest writers of our generation
are writing television
I would be the last person to say stop
binge watching
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon